we thought we talked about an issue that
has dominated the Democratic primary and
I'm not talking about why Tom Styer
doesn't look richer but why doesn't he
though his skin sallow his clothes don't
fit right and he seems to only have one
tie what is this man doing with all this
money
no we're not talking about that instead
we're gonna talk about this it's the hot
buzz phrase for Democrats running for
president Medicare for all we will have
Medicare for all we have a chance for
Medicare for all Medicare for all
Medicare for all now there's a lot of
talk about Medicare for all what does
that mean question from a great judge
and an even greater human being and to
answer the question from Ruth Bader
Ginsburg's inevitable successor what is
Medicare for all well right now we have
what's called a multi payor system what
that means is maybe your health care is
covered by private insurance purchased
by you or your employer or maybe it's
covered by a government program like
Medicare or Medicaid or maybe you're one
of the 27 million Americans with no
insurance in which case you the
basic idea behind Medicare for all is
that all of this would be replaced by a
government-funded single-payer program
and the goal of universal health care
coverage is extremely appealing both
Bernie Sanders and Elizabeth Warren have
put out versions of Medicare for all but
other Democrats have been much wary of
it and conservatives absolutely hate the
idea we cannot afford Medicare for all
this is the end of America as we know it
economically I think literally 90% of
hospitals would go under tomorrow right
Medicare for all I lived in England
short nationalized health care is a
disaster when rich famous people get
sick they don't fly to Canada they don't
fly to Cuba they come here because we
have the best medicine in the world no I
will give that man this America does
have one of the best health care systems
in the world for rich famous people
unfortunately too many people are born
in this country with a terrible
pre-existing condition called
not being beyond sir
some of us many of us in fact are still
launched and and for so many Americans
our system is badly broken and I'm not
just talking about the 27 million
without health insurance but the nearly
44 million more who are under in short
people with high deductibles and co-pays
that can end up bleeding them dry the
majority of people who file for
bankruptcy cite medical expenses as a
factor and you probably already knew
that deep down from just how often you
see GoFundMe campaigns online from
worried parents of six children or your
friend who got a pineapple stuck up his
ass and needs help paying the doctors to
stop laughing and get it out and
incidentally for all the heartwarming
success stories that you see a study
found 90% of crowdfunding campaigns for
medical expenses fail to meet their goal
and when they fall short it can be
crushing what just one family struggles
to raise $10,000 for expenses rising
from their two-year-old daughters eye
disorder
Sheila's fundraiser isn't going as well
as they'd hoped about a month in it only
raised six hundred ten dollars early
morning on the day of Sheila's surgery
her parents are still trying to get the
word out okay so we're gonna make her
sign hashtag eyes for Sheila very good
think about what you're looking at there
it's a pretty dystopian society that
we're living in if your physical and
financial well-being depend on whether
your crowdfunding campaign can get a
signal boost from jiff ponder Pomeranian
and good luck with that by the way I'll
be trying to get into post our
gerrymandering piece for months now and
he won't do it
come on jiff pond throw us a
bone you
the point is any solution that might put
an end to that is worth at least
considering surely and to be honest I
personally think there is a lot to be
said for Medicare for all so tonight
let's take a look at it not the politics
of whether it can pass but what it
actually is and whenever the subject
comes up you tend to hear three major
criticisms of it concerning costs wait
times and choice and let's start with
cost because critics will tell you that
Medicare for all will simply increase
the federal budget too much this sicko
socialism would cost roughly thirty two
point six trillion dollars over ten
years even if you doubled tax
collections from individuals and
corporations yes that means you'd be
paying twice what you already do in
taxes that still doesn't cover the tab
my god free health care is expensive
look I
I know that sounds dramatic but Sarah
Palin's fourth attempt at cloning
herself actually has a point there
Medicare for all would undeniably be
expensive but that fact needs a lot of
context around it for starters where it
would increase the federal budget yes
but it would also eliminate employer
spending on premiums and you're spending
on outer pocket pocket costs now would
those balance each other out that is a
good question the answer is no one can
possibly know for sure there are just
too many variables involved the Times
asked five prominent experts to estimate
national health care spending under
Bernie's plan and they compared that to
what we spend now and the results range
from it would actually cost us less - it
would cost about the same - it will cost
a of a lot more and I know that
extra shading does not look like very
much but believe me it's a of a lot
but good look let's say just for
argument's sake our overall spending did
go up we would be getting a lot for that
money
remember 27 million more people would be
covered and they'd be covered well
Bernie's plan is incredibly generous
it covers vision dental long-term care
and drugs in fact medicare for all is a
misleading title because Medicare
requires some co-pays and out-of-pocket
expenses and Bernie will excitedly tell
you his plan eliminates those under the
Medicare for all bill that I wrote
premiums are gone co-payments are gone
deductibles are gone all out-of-pocket
expenses are gone he's right hospital
bills are gone co-payments are gone
cellphone payments gone flat tires gone
Geico commercials gone all the things
you hate in this world will be gone and
all that will remain is universally
accessible health care and Laura Dern
finally life as it should be
Bernie's plan isn't just more generous
than most current private insurance
plans it's more generous than the policy
of any single-payer country on earth and
there is a good case to be made that
even if national spending wound up
higher we might wind up wasting less
right now a lot of our health care
spending doesn't go to health care it
goes to administrative costs that come
with having a vast insurance industry
that is clearly wildly inefficient and
consolidating all health insurance under
one roof would give the government far
more leverage to negotiate prices down
because look it is no secret prices for
procedures and drugs are out of control
in the United States it is so bad one
insurance provider in Utah recently
started offering some of its
participants cash if they were willing
to travel a little further than their
local pharmacy to fill out their
prescription it's called pharmaceutical
tourism here's how it works
PE HP puts patients on a plane and flies
them to San Diego from there a private
car takes them across the border to
Tijuana Mexico where their prescription
is waiting for them the only difference
the prescription costs roughly half the
price PHP will give people willing to
travel an additional $500 back cheaper
for us to pay for the drug down there
send them down there and then given them
$500 that's crazy giving you
$500 to go to Mexico to buy drugs it's
not what your insurance provider should
be doing it's what your sketchy friend
Meredith should be doing cuz she wants
to make Briana's bachelorette party a
total rager I go myself but I have
outstanding wines under Medicare for all
the government would be a much stronger
negotiator now you wouldn't want it to
set prices so low than it stifles
innovation or bankruptcy doctors but
that is a balance that you would need to
strike overall you can't definitely say
that it would be more expensive but even
if it was I personally would argue that
it's worth it and either way cost is a
lot more complicated and issue than just
going on TV and saying 32.6 Tyrolean
dollars like Tina Fey doing her best dr.
evil impression anyway the next major
criticism of Medicare for all concerns
wait times specifically that it would
result in rationing and delays to care
if you think it's fun to wait in line at
DMV you're gonna love Bernie Sanders
wait times for Medicare for all it leads
to the kind of care that people now have
in England or Canada where you have to
wait in line just take a look at Canada
or the UK it means long waiting lines it
means people not getting the health
treatments they need okay i s that no
one likes waiting in line for anything
I get it most people see the line at
Trader Joe's and either abandon their
cart or pull the fire alarm and sneak
out with their groceries undetected
unless I'm not saying I've ever done
that I'm just saying I've had a show to
do tonight
who wants some peanut butter pretzels
but as we've cost comparisons of wait
times are very complicated for one thing
the International wait times that you
hear about most often are for
non-emergency surgeries such as knee
replacements and while yes people in
other countries do sometimes have to
wait slightly longer for some care it's
not like Americans aren't having to do
that right now
anyway Americans are just sometimes
forced to wait due to the expense about
half of US adults say they or a family
member put off or skipped care in the
past year because of the cost and about
one in eight say their medical condition
got worse because of that delay as for
the uninsured they can won't wind up
having to wait on a literal line seeking
care with AIDS groups like remote area
medical an organization that travels the
country setting up mobile clinics to
treat people for free and which draws
massive lines wherever it goes having
got their place in line many can't add
for the night before dawn this was the
moment they were waiting for number one
come on down
number two number three one by one
patients are let in for their chance of
a visit to a doctor a dentist and an
optician at first
Graham focused on communities in remote
areas of developing countries but Stan
says he gradually came to realize the
depth of need in the u.s. today
Oh 80% or more of what we do is here in
the United States it's unbelievable to
me
that is the case normally Americans hate
it when a British person comes over to
diagnose what's wrong with you believe
me six seasons of YouTube comments have
made that very clear the
internet is me and for all critics talk
of wait times abroad it is worth knowing
less than 10 percent of Britons or
Canadians say that their health system
needs to be rebuilt completely compared
to 23 percent of people here in the
United States in fact when London hosted
the 2012 Olympics the opening ceremony
featured a four and a half minute
celebration of the National Health
Service featuring swing dancing doctors
and nurses and children jumping up and
down on hospital beds as per Canada they
adore their health service so much that
when they had a contest for the greatest
Canadian of all time this was the result
the greatest Canadian as decided by you
is Tommy
the mother of all national titles goes
to the father of Medicare family Ingenix
but we're going to ignore that if it was
the nineteen thirties and that one
perfect look there is the final big
criticism of Medicare parole which
involves choice specifically that it
would take away our ability to choose
the sort of health coverage that we
receive when I hear that health care is
a right what I hear is health care will
no longer have choices under Medicare
for all your choice of health coverage
disappears Americans are still Americans
we're not socialists we're not
communists we like choice and we like to
have choice in health care especially
what Americans are Americans it's true
and they do like having choices it's why
the number one rated series on Netflix
is 40 minutes of looking through the
menu for something good it's basically
America's national pastime and the fact
that is a full cosine on that concept
but the fact is the fact is our current
system limits Americans choices far more
than it expands them for starters as a
practical matter most of us don't choose
our health insurance we get what we get
through our employer and because of that
choices like changing jobs can become
significantly harder and not just that
oftentimes your choice of doctors and
hospitals is severely limited by which
ones your insurance will cover going out
of your insurance network can be
prohibitively expensive that is why
people bend over backwards to stay
in-network
and even when they do that it can still
all go horribly wrong while campaigning
in 2018 Democratic congresswoman Katie
Porter's appendix burst her first
thought how much would it cost I didn't
call an ambulance cuz I knew it could
cost a lot if you call an ambulance
specifically had my manager drives me
back to the closest hospital but to the
in-network hospital even though the
hospital was in her Network the surgeon
who helped save Porter's life was not
and she got a bill for nearly three
thousand dollars exactly you can get
by taking an ambulance you can
get by going to the wrong
hospital or you can get by going
to the right hospital but getting the
wrong surgeon the American healthcare
system gives you so many choices as to
how you want to get it truly is
become a suture and I'm gonna care for
all that scenario would not happen no
doctor would be out of network because
there wouldn't be a network at all and
the truth about Americans current
illusion of choice is that too often
because of cost the choices our current
system forces people to make are ones
like this I prioritize the hard stuff
over the insulin because the hard stuff
is more immediate I know over time you
know diabetes will kill me but it'll
take a longer time and I know that
without the heart failure drugs I only
have 13% function of my heart I don't
want play with that that's obviously
terrible a humane health care system
should not require people to pick their
favorite organ although for the record
if you're ever asking me my favorite
organ I'm going spleen every time now I
know the brain in the heart get all the
attention but I'm telling you when it
comes to filtering blood you can't go
wrong with the spleen hash tag on the
spleen staing hashtag yes Lee
so so those are those are the three main
criticisms of medicare-for-all and I
should say it is not just people on the
right who raised them some Democrats
have reservations to Pete Budaj for
instance prefers a different concept to
Medicare for all but with a catchy
similar name my healthcare vision is
Medicare for all who wanted let every
American have the choice to walk away
from the corporate private plans and
toward something better but when they're
ready because I trust Americans to make
that right choice okay well hold on
there you trust Americans to make the
right choice you know Americans choose
to drink Bud Light
right which doesn't taste like beer so
much as it tastes like if clear somehow
died and was discovered in this
apartment three weeks later but but what
Buddha Church is referring to when he
says Medicare for all who wanted is
basically the public option that is
where the government doesn't replace the
private insurance system it just
introduces its own plan that would
compete with it and it would definitely
be an improvement over what we have now
the problem is it would leave so much of
our current insurance infrastructure
with all of its problems intact so
that's kind of like being offered either
a sandwich or a slightly smaller
sandwich with guac I mean I guess
I'll take the second one if you're
asking but honestly the lack of guac
wasn't really my main concern
and I'm not saying any of this would be
easy a lot would have to be figured out
from how to impose the taxes to pay for
it in an equitable way to the
consequences of eliminating the entire
private health insurance industry which
by one estimate could displace 1.8
million workers that is a legitimate
thing to be concerned about and any plan
would have to be designed and rolled out
very very carefully that is why both
Warren and Saunders talked about the
need for transition plans for workers in
their proposals and I get that big
change is scary it is human nature to
prefer the devil you know over an
uncertain alternative but the devil you
know is still a devil and and it is easy
to forget that I on Britain a lot
on this show
I'm not gonna stop anytime soon but one
thing Britain does well is the National
Health Service it's not perfect of
course I'm not gonna swing dance on a
bed about it but I will be
honest with you I've never had a bad
experience and I don't know anyone who
has
but since moving to America I don't
think I have met anyone who doesn't have
at least one insurance industry horror
story at this point the u.s. national
anthem should just be everyone in the
stadium yelling about their insurance
company for two and a half minutes so
for what it is worth
personally I am in favor of some version
of carefully designed universal health
coverage and I will own all the things
about it that are difficult including
the fact that politically it would be
incredibly hard to get passed but in
return anyone who is resistant to
significant change is going to have to
own all the flaws of our current system
one in which when Americans get sick
they can find themselves
comparison-shopping with a burst
appendix flipping a coin between
life-saving medications and praying they
can come up with a catchy enough hashtag
to cover their care although for what
it's worth on that one until we fix this
mess if anyone gets a ruptured
spleen please feel free to use hashtag
yeah that's all yours good luck with it
[Applause]